Film Courage: How much did it cost you to
start Film Threat?
Chris Gore, Founder/Owner of FilmThreat/Author/Filmmaker:
Oh wow… well it cost me nothing because
I wrote a bad check and it bounced oh okay
this is when we would write checks for things
so I yeah to start Film Threat I mean I guess
the real investment was I bought a book about
how to publish a magazine because based on
my college education I kind of felt like well
I'm paying them all this money to buy really
expensive versions of books and then regurgitate
the contents of those books in the form of
essays or questionnaires when I can just buy
the books and read those books recreationally
to because being filled with knowledge was
the thing that was important to me not proving
to a professor that I had read the book but
I bought a book from folio magazine which
is the magazine about the magazine business
it's like variety for magazines and I bought
a book from them about how to publish a magazine
and read that book and realize there was no
way I was going to be able to do it but I
the first issue was six pages and I had put
it together I had like the logo which I had
created and sort of a fan zine I like the
title 'Film Threat,' it sounded punk rock
and
I was a big fan of I was a big fan of like
old school fanzines they were mostly about
music and skateboarding and while I loved
music could not skateboard I loved movies
I wanted to do a fanzine about movies Film
Threat just seemed to fit with all of those
so I met a guy named Andre Seawood at my school
at Wayne state university and he had written
some very thoughtful essays very complex about
politics and film most of which I didn't understand
but I thought well look here's a platform
I’ll do jokes and come up with sort of comedic
things and movie parody posters and whatnot
I’ll write some reviews myself and you can
put your essays in this and we put out this
magazine we put out the first issue which
was six pages and I wrote a check it was I
believe the check was for like maybe 50 and
it it bounced there were only 500 copies of
the first issue of Film Threat that were published
but but sorry who did you sorry interrupt
but who did you write the check to Kinkos
so yeah I wrote I wrote the check to Kinko's
and it bounced and I there were charges from
the bank anyways eventually I then paid that
off and then I did come up with a way by selling
advertising to be able to pay for the magazine
it wasn't expensive at that level Andre and
I parted ways later and I wanted to really
get the magazine up to a much higher not like
a 12-page thing I wanted to do something more
substantial so I went into a printer and I
said I learned about this thing called credit
and I went into a printer in in Detroit and
I said could you print this movie on cred
print this magazine on credit and I had walked
in with a business suit that I bought from
like value village was the name of the place
which was sort of a salvation army I bought
it at Value Village for five dollars I walked
in with this suit I looked really professional
even though I was very boyish looking face
at the time and I just said well you printed
on credit and they said yes and I did this
I did the same scam to another printer and
then another printer another printer to the
point where then like the sheriff's department
was like look you you have to pay these printers
money I had them coming after me at the time
i'd amassed a huge record collection and sold
it all to be able to pay the printers off
so I basically just sold like all the stuff
that I had just to be able to keep the creditors
off my back and then that actually got the
attention of an investor who thought that
Film Threat like oh this is crazy story of
this kid who was like defrauding like printers
in Detroit to print a magazine and so he decided
to invest in it and then so there are very
stages of Film Threat there's the zine stage
getting it printed at like off of a copy machine
then the more formal magazine stage and then
the stage where I sold the magazine in and
eventually sold it to Larry Flynt and there's
a whole story there where I licensed it to
him for a dollar which I never got but he
didn't pay me anything for the magazine what
I ended up getting was I got free advertising
in the magazine and I got a a budget to work
with actually so I sort of ca I sort of split
Film Threat into two magazines one being Film
Threat magazine which was published by LFP
Larry Flynt publications and the second magazine
was called Film Threat video guide which we
and we had a rule that any movie that was
made for under say a hundred thousand dollars
really low budget or underground films we
put those in Film Threat video guide and then
Film Threat magazine did the bigger budget
indie movies right the ones were made for
about a million or so this was in the 90s
and so we had sort of cleared delineations
and then we would do a section in Film Threat
called underground where we would cover the
magazines or highlights of the the movies
that were covered in Film Threat video guide
so they were like these sister publications
and that led to creating a distribution label
where we put out people like Todd Phillips
his first documentary called hated about Gigi
Allen and the Murder Junkies so we put out
Todd Phillips first documentary film on VHS
in the 90s and that sort of kicked off our
company we put out about 30 different films
on VHS and Film Threat video guide basically
championed those movies and the reason that
company started is because filmmakers would
come to us and they would say we'd love to
advertise our movie that we're releasing on
VHS ourselves in Film Threat video guide we'd
say okay well advertising costs this much
a page and they'd say we don't have the money
so we figured out a way like well how about
this we're not going to get the rights to
your movies we're just going to give you free
advertising we'll do fulfillment for you and
then we'll pay you a larger percentage of
what the money we take in right so we did
VHS duplication and we were basically giving
we never owned the movies per se it was like
a licensed deal and then we would sell these
filmmakers movies on VHS at the time and built
up like York Bucharet's film necromantic we
put out his second film Dirtotis King and
he was a german filmmaker that helped him
get distribution in other countries so we
championed smaller films made by like Richard
Kern is one of the filmmakers among others
Todd Phillips put out his documentary and
then we put out a series of short films put
out by the New York underground film festival
so we had these very distinct delineations
between the two Film Threat was the more mainstream
snarky giving the middle finger to Hollywood
bigger budget indie movies and then Film Threat
video guide was the smaller underground films
and movies that we actually were distributing
and helping the filmmakers make money selling
their movies how did you meet Larry Flynt
how I met Larry Flynt was after he noticed
me I was writing and comedy for Hustler Magazine
they had this section in the front that was
just sort of it was like mad magazine but
a very, very adult version of it and I wrote
jokes for it and he loved what I did he thought
that I did like movie parodies I did a parody
a film parody The Revenge of Anne Frank which
was Anne Frank as a zombie risen from the
dead to kill nazi skinheads I grew up in Detroit
around and skinheads existed that would and
I thought that they were very obnoxious I
did not like them so that inspired me to come
up with that concept and that was one among
many of the the jokes that I put in that section
anyways he really liked the stuff that I was
writing in there and I pitched to Jim Coles
who was the CFO of the company I said look
I said Hustler magazine is like a punk rock
adult magazine right you have Playboy and
then you got Hustler punk rock at the time
they published a magazine called RIP which
was a heavy metal magazine and RIP is like
this angry punk rock metal magazine it's sort
of the opposite of rolling stone I said what
you need you need a punk rock movie magazine
you've got adult content you've got rip magazine
music how about film and and that concept
was taken to Jim Coles who ran the company
at the time and he loved the concept so I
met Larry Flynt it was it was I mean it was
strange to meet him I mean here here I am
a college dropout he gave me an opportunity
and for for that I will be forever grateful
and his his fight for the first amendment
is admirable and it's a lot of the freedoms
we enjoy the freedom of the press things that
we're able to say are specifically because
of Larry I mean he he really nearly gave up
his life for that if about his history so
he was shot yeah I mean he was shot and crippled
so but Larry was fearless I mean that really
inspired me with Film Threat at the time as
well I mean my passion wasn't necessarily
adult content but my passion was film and
just that he gave me a voice to be able at
a budget to be able to put out this magazine
at the time was pretty incredible so I’m
really grateful will always be forever grateful
for him giving me a boost and and getting
Film Threat magazine on newsstands all over
the country didn't anyone talk you out of
starting Film ThreatI know you you started
it with someone yes college okay my family
tried to talk me out of doing Film Threatthey
say they said it's never going to make any
money and I will say this they're not wrong
Film Threathas almost never made money it's
it's break even is a huge success having said
that break even with breaking even with what
we're able to do in the indie film community
I think is a worthwhile trade additionally
I wouldn't have had a a career on television
or had offers to do books or other opportunities
if I didn't have film thread as kind of as
this thing that I do so what Film Threat really
brought to me was opportunity have I made
money on it no am I still here yes have I
outlived other media outlets plenty and I
feel that's I mean and there would be little
pretenders and i'd see like other people start
things like oh that's really interesting let's
see how you do with that it's not easy to
be consistent it's not easy to have done something
this is now more than half my life I mean
it's I've been doing I started film thread
in 1985. so I don't know when you're watching
this or when you're listening to this but
I started at 1985 okay and Film Threat is
still around maybe not in the year 2100 who
knows but still going still going strong and
so I feel that there's respect for what we're
doing and it's just amazing to me that the
mission has remained consistent at a time
when brands reinvent themselves and I think
reinvent themselves in a way that almost like
it just gets away from like well what are
you you started this way now you're this it's
not what people are we've remained consistent
and I’ll say it's there's been no shortage
of sacrifice for that so they toss you out
just just ask my butler and by that I mean
I don't have a butler okay so they talked
you out of it before you left Michigan yeah
before I left Michigan my family was trying
to talk me out of talked me out of continuing
to do Film Threat there was always like I
every time i'd reach a milestone I would revisit
it it's been five years eight 1985 to 1990
I even did like a fake tombstone photo shoot
with filmed the Film Threat logo on a tombstone
1985 to 1990. I thought five years is a good
round number I’ll stop 10 years is a good
round number I’ll stop 25 years is a good
round number I’ll stop but here I am it's
more than 30 years later and it's this thing
that I'm kind of burdened with always being
connected to but it has brought me a lot of
a lot a lot of opportunity and I feel gratified
from the standpoint of I have I hope I have
inspired some filmmakers who who look at what
we're doing and see that it's possible to
get attention the thing that does concern
me is how lazy the media is I think that our
mainstream entertainment industrial complex
are lazy from the standpoint of they're pretty
much run by the press release that goes into
their inbox and that and and run by publicists
that are effectively ghostwriting a lot of
stories and there's a laziness from the standpoint
of this movie is opening on 6 000 screens
so that's the movie I'm going to cover but
there's 10 other movies that are coming out
the same weekend why why are you not covering
those and that has been my frustration I would
probably quit doing Film Threat if there was
some other outlet that just paid attention
or at least if one of the larger outlets paid
attention to the small filmmakers so we review
anything I mean if you send your movie to
film thread if you go and you submit it we
have a little submission system if you send
it to us we'll review it there's no I mean
I would recommend that you be somewhat beyond
either you're playing at a film festival or
you're about to come out in commercial release
right and the sooner you submit it the better
it helps us out we get five or six hundred
movies submitted to us on a monthly basis
we try to cover about half so we do our best
but it just disappoints me that when I meet
other colleagues who cover film like I do
that we can sit there and talk forever about
the latest marvel movie but they have no clue
what other movies are coming out and I can
sit there and tell you about psycho gourmand
or clapboard jungle or like a host of other
movies that have come out all different types
of genres to your last death an indie animated
comedy horror anime I mean it's just like
these bizarre movies that are coming out of
all types and there there's a complete lack
of awareness about them and there's an elitism
about them as well and I feel and I'm sure
I said this before in one of the other interviews
you need to have a balanced media diet it
is important it's important that you see a
film made by a new up-and-coming filmmaker
that is just trying and it's like to me these
movies are like birds with broken wings they
are not perfect they are not perfect and that's
okay because what I feel part of my role part
of our role at Film Threat is to kind of take
that bird and just let it fly as high as it
possibly can and to look beyond the yes there
may not be may not be technically perfect
there may be some rough around the edges things
but you can see if you can see a creative
vision beyond the flaws I live for that I
love that I love that that sense of discovery
that this is a new creative voice that this
first movie this first short whatever it is
not perfect but some that there's something
there and if that filmmaker can just get a
little bit of encouragement to want to keep
going that that means a lot so you've been
a part of Film Threat for over 30 years but
it didn't always rest in your hands so you
had Larry Flynt publications that took over
it and then how did you get it back from that
point well there were a couple times a Film
Threat for me Film Threat is like a villain
in a James Cameron movie like you think you've
killed it and it rises again so I mean the
the first time was in like 1990 I decided
I'm just gonna put Film Threat down I'm going
to go do other stuff and then I was somehow
able to finagle Larry Flynt to buy the magazine
and then I went off to go work at a video
game company called digital pictures in Northern
California my I was asked with making small
low budget independent features that would
also be developed into video games a guy hired
me named Tom Zito they developed movies called
Night Trap and Sewer Shark you can look those
up they were made for like the Sega cd this
was the very first cd-rom what they called
full motion video games so I worked for that
company and developed some movie projects
that would have also been video game projects
so we take we've got an 18-day schedule to
make the movie then we add on six extra days
to make the video game well that was short-lived
and when I left Film Threat was not in my
hands anymore I was not editing the magazine
it was edited by a guy named Paul Zimmerman
and Film Threat was always teetering on the
edge of profitability and the bean counters
over at Larry Flynt decided to pull the plug
there were some people that were interested
in buying it at the time the publisher of
Spy magazine and Psychology Today had a group
of magazines and looked to purchase it that
deal fell through Paul Zimmerman tried to
find some investors to purchase it to do to
continue to do it and then when all of those
deals fell through I because I had left LFP
on very good terms I talked to my old boss
Jim Coles the CFO and he said look he said
I can give it to you but you have to take
over the subscription liability which is about
thirty thousand dollars so meaning I had to
fulfill the subscriptions because that was
the debt that they had owed the subscribers
who had pre-paid for issues of the magazine
that were unfulfilled so I relaunched Film
Threat as a print magazine in 1996 and we
only put out like two or three issues about
two issues there was a third issue that was
about to go to press and it was very it was
really depressing it was so funny that second
issue we put Courtney Love on the cover because
the People Vs. Larry Flynt was about to come
out and I did we interview for that was it
the director what's so funny is now this is
I'm having a Shatner moment where people will
walk up to Shatner remember that episode of
Star Trek well people walk up to me and they
say remember that issue of Film Threat and
I'm like I kind of have a vague memory but
I usually I have to check I don't actually
have a full collection of the magazine by
the way there I'm missing some issues of the
magazine in any case that was the last issue
that was published there was a third issue
that was that with we had a David Lynch cover
story that never went to press because this
was 1997 and there was a paper crisis so a
bunch of things happened simultaneously and
my some people have a conspiracy theory that
they think that this was a way to suppress
alternative media I don't 100 believe it but
at the time there was a paper crisis and in
in the late 90’s and they jacked up the
prices of paper additionally ad agencies that
had booked like cigarette and good paying
ads they decided not to pay these small publishers
I'm talking about magazines like the nose
from San Francisco bay area among other like
alternative press we're talking about everything
across the realm or music film and a lot of
magazines went under Film Threat being among
them there were there was it was like this
perfect storm of paper raising in prices distributors
that couldn't pay us and went out of business
one in particular in Texas called flatland
distribution additionally another advertising
agencies deciding to just like not pay their
bills I mean it was it was fairly typical
for an agency to book an ad and pay you between
six months 18 months later you had to plan
for that you had to plan for the fact that
an ad that you were gonna get paid like maybe
eight thousand dollars five thousand dollars
you would not receive that money for six months
that was normal so you had to always act like
you don't have money so that's that would
be really good advice to actors when you get
that big payday actors don't pretend you don't
have that money pretend it doesn't exist learn
to live inexpensively live a good life but
inexpensively and sorry who was behind this
conspiracy though who was who were they this
is people within the publishing industry felt
that because part of the reason for the rise
in paper prices because because the u.s government
would not allow a type of hemp to be grown
one that did not make a type of hemp that
could be grown that could be used for paper
for magazines that would not make you high
that these plants would not get you it would
not alter your and so so that actually would
would mean that you would not have to def
there wouldn't be no deforestation it's replenishable
you grow this type of hemp a strain of hemp
that doesn't get you high basically to use
for paper for magazines and newspapers but
the us government did not allow that to happen
and because of that paper prices went up and
that effectively muffled the voices of a lot
of magazines in that period Film Threat being
among them and I I'm not saying I'm saying
I had heard sure people say that because of
that it was the government trying to suppress
alternative media political political voices
anyone that had anyone that had a voice that
was not the mainstream narrative those voices
were suppressed it ended up being a blessing
in disguise because Film Threat collapsing
as a print magazine led to us creating an
email newsletter that went out to about a
hundred thousand people we had built it up
using it wasn't intended for this at the time
but we used Yahoo Groups probably no one remembers
yahoo groups but we used it as a way to do
a blast you could send notifications well
we just used it to send out our movie reviews
so we we created a thing called Film Threat
weekly which we put out every week and it
was just reviews of movies the top box office
we would include jokes we would have a quote
from a movie at the top we'd give you the
volume number the date this is very unsophisticated
this is before then then we had a website
right which was HTML I've been through every
incarnation of the internet right HTML I know
all the like the dot PHP and the this like
I'm not particularly technically sophisticated
but I like to push the medi as far as you
can the current incarnation of Film Threat
is built on Wordpress but we use a lot of
customized things that are written for it
to feature the movies I like I know that we
don't get as much traffic because we don't
if you go to traditional websites there's
stuff all over the front page we don't do
that what I like to do is I want you to look
at and we feature every movie that we review
we feature on our home page and if you scroll
through that home page it's I want to create
the feel of the cover of a magazine so that
every filmmaker whether it's a small film
or a larger film they're featured in a way
that features their the the photography from
the movie we we look for a key image we call
it the hero image and we want to make it look
we want we want to make the film look really
good even if the review might not be good
it's not always good we want to make the film
we want to present it in its best light and
we want to give it almost a magazine feel
that this is like look how important this
small movie is right and we give those just
as much attention as we would give a big budget
Hollywood release so yeah I've been through
it all Film Threat has lived and now there
was a time you asked about Film Threat changing
hands in 2010 I wanted to pursue I wanted
to pursue other things more filmmaking aspects
and whatnot and a guy who had worked for me
Mark Bell who I'm still friends with and and
mark's just my hero for a number of reasons
I mean my family we're all very close Mark
he took it over I wanted to like take a step
back and in 2010 Mark took Film Threat over
and we agreed on a payment price that he would
pay for it and he would just pay me a little
bit like every six months he'd give me a report
and and pay me for this amount that we had
we had determined as it is he wasn't able
to pay that off and the rights to Film Threat
reverted back to me in 2015. I kind of put
it on ice for a little bit and I did a Kickstarter
that was not successful and I and i'll say
this what I learned about Kickstarter is this
if you want to create a successful Kickstarter
do an unsuccessful one first because that's
your market research it tells you the things
people like and dislike about your campaign
it it informs you of the the how effective
your messaging is secondly you'll see really
what the market is willing to bear I think
I set too high a price even though it was
really the money I needed it was it was too
high I relaunched the campaign asked for less
money offered different rewards and Film Threat
was relaunched in January of 2017 with some
some or most of our legacy content intact
and we've continued to build build it ever
since we post about five times a day on the
site generally about three reviews a couple
news stories or features and then trailers
we run a lot of trailers that other trailer
sites don't run are you I still don't know
how to do youtube so I Youtube is a mystery
to me even though Film Threat does have a
Youtube channel we do interview filmmakers
and we do movie reviews and we do movie trailers
I don't know what people want on on youtube
so I know what I like and I like reviews and
I like interviews with filmmakers and I like
to see trailers that I don't see on other
traditional trailer channels so we like to
host trailers for indie filmmakers that you
wouldn't find these trailers and other channels
in fact I know for a fact that our content
gets ripped off from our channel all the time
it's fine it's I mean trailer is a piece of
marketing it's advertising it's good if someone's
looking to like bootleg the trailer and put
it on a different youtube channel good let
that happen it's more exposure for the for
the filmmaker it's more exposure for that
movie but yeah Film Threa thas changed hands
I've kind of like no matter what even when
I'm when the periods in which I was not involved
with film thread people would always blame
me for it so it seemed to be this thing that
would haunt me whether it was doing something
good or something bad i'd get credit when
it was good and people would be upset with
me it was bad and but there have been other
shepherds who have brought Film Threat along
and I don't know if it's some foolishness
or just not wanting to give up but here I
am like since 1985 doing a job that was like
right out of high school I kind of created
for myself and what does your family say now
well yeah I get I guess my family like they
finally kind of see like oh wow like like
I see Film Threat stuff pop up like it'll
be in their Youtube feeds or it'll like they'll
see a news story or like and they'll always
be like a story back in Michigan where I'm
from there'll be a story that pops up of like
famous people from Michigan and I get mentioned
in that which is really weird to me but I
guess it's I guess now they're they they recognize
that hey I think they probably like the tv
stuff more because that's more accessible
to them than reading an indie movie website
but there'll be those stories that pop up
every once in a while when they talk about
and and so they like it what can I say when
you were about to make the trip out here to
LA were you 19, 20, 21? I don't know I was
in my early 20’s it was 1989 so I was like
23-24 around there and moved to Los Angeles
and just loaded up a truck and came out here
didn't know what I was doing moved into Hollywood
I don't recommend Hollywood I don't recommend
Hollywood let me give you some some advice
here on moving if you're going to move here
one if you are pursuing independent film you
don't need to move here you don't you really
don't I you don't need to live in Hollywood
that's for sure what I like to do and especially
now we have the in whenever whenever I'm looking
to move is I will look at police reports in
the neighborhood I’ll go to a place I like
I use an app called I've used an app called
Padmapper which is a great way because it's
geo-based I find a neighborhood I like first
I see houses or places in that neighborhood
and then I like to live in a walkable neighborhood
i'll just say that Hollywood people who live
here will tell you to not live there it's
it's crime ridden and kind of disgusting but
I moved there when I first moved here got
out of my six months leaf lease as soon as
that was up and tried out every different
area I kind of lived in Los Feliz for a bit
I lived off Melrose Avenue I lived on on the
west side closer to Santa Monica I really
like that even though it was like prohibitively
expensive but it was really clean air one
thing that was very interesting after I just
moved to Los Angeles and went to my doctor
and I said I’ve had these sniffles I felt
like a cold that won't go away for six months
because you didn't have a cold you developed
allergies you moved from one location to here
and the environment like you have allergies
so I developed that after moving from a different
place but I do think it's important to really
check out that neighborhood and be mindful
of your situation put yourself in a situation
where you're going to be able to be productive
in terms of your work output one thing I live
in Pasadena and Pasadena is where castle green
is castle green is this beautiful you can
look this up castle green is Tim Burton lived
there when he was in school famously wrote
some of his early work was written at castle
green and if you ever see castle green in
Pasadena you'll see why it inspired his early
work Frankenweenie Beetlejuice Peewee's Big
Adventure you could see that like oh this
this this inspiration this beautiful old building
and a lot of movies were shot at castle green
it's quite the location a lot of weddings
happened there but now it's all condos it's
been it's this old hotel that have been turned
into condos and he lived there I do think
that your my living space for example and
where I work and find inspiration is really
important to me I have things that inspire
me whether it's like toys that I had from
when I was a kid I have a dune sand worm that
I got when the original David Lynch Dune came
out certain books will be facing forward so
I can see the cover of those books I do think
that a spate your creative space wherever
that is is just really important and I've
come to enjoy when I find these on youtube
the term the friend told me is it's like either
ambient or slow tv they call it slow tv which
is a thing where it's just sort of a sound
and it just sort of gets you into that trance
like in the zone so that you can work really
effectively and I will usually cons a couple
hours of slow tv a day to get into that space
so I can get certain tasks accomplished so
I think really be mindful of that if you're
healing hearing helicopters in your neighborhood
probably not the best neighborhood to be in
and there are places on the outskirts of la
proper that I think are they're beautiful
parts of Burbank Glendale Pasadena North Hollywood
that I would strongly recommend and if you
could live in a walkable neighborhood that's
great too and even better a walkable neighborhood
close to the metro I live three blocks the
metro I can hop on the metro and boom I'm
in downtown LA I can hop in the metro and
boom I'm at the TCL theater in in the heart
of Hollywood right and they're expanding those
lines some of some of these metro lines are
going to other parts of LA that it's just
exciting because it didn't exist when I first
moved to Los Angeles that didn't exist in
1989 they broke ground it was like what 1991-1992
they broke ground on building the metro now
it's everywhere and I i take it a lot I like
having to not have to worry about parking
and I don't know parking in LA that's a whole
other that's a whole other episode.
Question For The Viewers:
What is your favorite Film Threatepisode?